j'ai eu l'information les faits que
certaines personnes ayant encore
aujourd'hui ont des répercussions de
trois emplois très difficile parce
qu'ils sont venus confesse et leurs
péchés donc est ce que ce sont des gens
qui le refusent d'emploi vont dire d'un
côté tu as fait des choses qui sont
n'accepte pas engagé est ce que c'est ça
ou c'est peut-être une espèce de fait de
de conséquence en est un gâteau toutes
deux par les tapas garder la distance
tommy a mis à jour les problématiques
on peut se poser la question mais c'est
certain qu'il ya plusieurs personnes qui
sont venues témoigner qui encore des
conséquences aujourd'hui
suit alors des moniales malgré les
protections offertes par la loi
principalement la loi ces commissions d
enquête et vraisemblablement est très
priori c'est à dire que ce jeu halak au
chai l'argent pour aller à la coupe et
des avantages en ce moment raisons et
dans la vie de tous les jours en
pratique ça peut-être pour la protection
requise cet article